Who, who are er,
er working here as general work,
er people is because in the Immigration Act,
which you are changing now in the White Paper,
it talks about people having to go to the department of Labour
to get a certificate
that there is no South African who can perform that part of
type of job. And then,
with that certificate, they come to all my fairs.
That has proven not to be very practical,
but that's what parliament passed in 2,002.
So, in each place,
we are replacing it with what you call a point base system,
that to come and do general work in South Africa,
you must score certain points.
And the points are going to be, eh,
We are going to put them out in the public
to gazette them for public commence
for South Africans to tell us, eh,
whether they agree with particular points or not.
This is things about age, about experience,
about qualifications,
about where you have been waking before, etcetera, etcetera.
And we think that will solve this problem,
not rhetoric of just sitting here making noise.
Remember, issues of immigration are very serious, global.
It's not only a South African problem,
is a global problem, if you check all over the world
where they are dealing with this problem.
So they need the sober mind.
And we have put that sobriety in our white paper
and in all the proposals that we are making.
The, the,
the The
the issue er er of foreigners taking jobs will be resolved by this
secondly, because all countries when they want immigration,
you want mostly skilled people.
Now I want to answer a question from E F f
when they started about Africa Continental Free Trade Agreement.
The Africa
Continental Free Trade Agreement have got five areas of engagement.
None of them talks about open borders.
They are talking about goods moving freely through borders,
people moving freely through borders,
but with documentation, certain tariffs being reduced,
certain carries been reduced and certain goods not being text etcetera.
That's Africa Continental Free Trade Agreement. Alright.
We are trading with each other and
and so it's a misnomer to say it means there must be no border.
It's not true at all.
Just a quick question before I move on to Mister Mani.